oh that's so brutal yeah and he doesn't
have a lot of time and now after king d7
rook takes rogue knight takes the shot
[Music]
group c logic versus tubo
never in a million years hikaru did i
expect a grammy-nominated rapper
to compete against a minecraft minecraft
streamer yeah
no i can't do it
i can't do it it's all falling apart the
whole operation
i don't know if i'm ready for logic the
rapper the dubs doves are
on the case and we're finally gonna have
the game between logic and oh here we go
the game has started it looks like
e4 yep okay hikaru uh
what do we know about logic man i think
we know that logic
a little bit that i know is that he
likes play e4 e5 symmetrical setups um
beyond that i don't know a whole lot i
would say
his understanding is pretty good overall
i feel like he's he's got a good
good fundamental grasp of the basics um
i think he's a very slight favorite here
the one thing i would say about tubbo
though is i feel like tubbo has had a
lot of experience he's played a lot more
chess
right so oh wow okay
four wow is it gonna try to do the the
the the
hobo sin fish hook with h5 is is a big
question mark here
um i like you know i don't even
well you're saying that uh yeah castle's
h3h5 uh-huh
okay yes yes he's gonna try to maybe try
to go for the fish hook as
uh as forest and called it there's only
one way as far as i see in this position
that logic could run into trouble
and that is bishop f2 king e2 knight d4
correct correct bishop okay let's play
out this sequence so bishop there
right he's threatened that horse that's
threatening that was he's probably just
gonna
take it with his horse i take with my
horse okay
i think that's the play we worked on
pins a lot
where was this degree of analysis and
patience when he gave away his queen for
a bishop
like that's a good point actually right
he is he he's now he's much more patient
he's working it out logically whereas
before
he was very very like just that nervous
energy and and moving too quickly it's
actually a very good point
how good are logic's checkmate patterns
what if he plays bishop e8 hoping for
rookie 8 knight f7
oh that would be beautiful although
actually 97 is a very good move by logic
the other thing i realize with logic is
that he is a very he's going to use his
time
and in general that's a good thing but
if he if he does kind of what xpc was
doing it gets a little bit too low on
time
bad things could happen that being said
he castles very quickly and now i think
he's looking very very good here
yeah once he's castled it's all good
and night h7 is a great move as well by
logic
um yeah it looks like it looks like
logic is off to a flying start here and
i think this is
this is just just what the doctor
ordered um
for logic especially he is one of i
think one of the favorites potentially
and so to get a very smooth kind of
good start i think it's really important
however
and threaten the queen get him away from
that oh oh oh oh we're cafe
oh oh
oh wait a minute
wait a minute okay i need to think
everything through oh he's slipping
for a minute oh no he slips oh my gosh
oh no he can check right he can check me
okay can i get some can i get some
komodo hypes in the chat
wait oh no he made a mouse slip oh my
gosh
oh but it's he's still in the game after
bishop takes queen he can take the black
rook he's still in the game weirdly
yes he is still in the game and he could
actually be winning in the course of a
move
unbelievable but the thing is this tub
of see the king move that's the question
he does yeah
yeah and uh well yeah you see uh
actually
logic plays rook fade he doesn't even
take the rook yeah
because he's obviously thinking about
that move anyway and he sees that he's
going to
oh man this is oh that's so unfortunate
for logic
oh man look down i wonder if he was on
click click or if he was on
oh man dragging but
oh that's so brutal yeah and he doesn't
have a lot of time and now after king d7
rook takes rogue nightmares what is this
doing oh my god you just what does tubo
do here exactly
i don't know i actually don't see i mean
i see a way to give up the rook and and
still be fine but it's never gonna
happen
yeah but now b7 b7 oh my gosh this
oh it's game on again oh this is
absolutely unbelievable according to the
computer black is still winning if
and only if black takes the rook and
brings back the knight but then black
has to
coordinate a rook bishop knight man with
a minute and 20. like wow
okay you move the king oh my gosh this
this hikaru the cc can you take the rook
oh because kingdom rugby won yes exactly
so king b2
hide behind your pawn logic
oh he went the wrong way i
oh ro g2
oh just don't go king e3 king e3 was
mate
but will tubble make a this might be a
draw i could see this being a draw
yeah because logic obviously is is on
the but also tableau is no time
oh no oh yeah yo now you make a queen
and now logic is gonna win the game oh
my gosh that's unbelievable
oh wow oh what a turnaround all the
ambulance
call the ambulance
okay so let's see what logic is going to
do he still has time this is
probably it's going to do it the other
way where he now pushes the pawn i think
exactly push the pawn
exactly you don't even think i just
think logic does
he's just he feels he's feeling nerves
and he doesn't want to go into the end
game to begin with
i think he's feeling the nerves and he's
too worried that he's gonna make a
stallmate with the king and queen
oh but now queen d6 and king c4 yeah
exactly i mean he might push two well
the queen d6 yeah
very nice move
that's clean very clean
it's a good game by logic man uh to
create that counter play on the queen
side that was
not that was not a 1076 flame
that was a high level play is there any
stalemates here
with two queens there is xcc has done it
a few times
um we're basically like queen d7 king h6
queen of seven i think the temples are
wrong oh
whoa that is really strange now there is
none yeah just queen
any queen okay that's good too clean
yep what that was a good game honestly
that was a good game by logic like
literally he was only losing because he
slipped
that's it right yeah objectively you're
right it's a very clean game definitely
a deserved win for him
although the game did get very very wild
bouncy up and down
after that
is that what's going on here
wow what a game what a game
uh i think that we should focus on our
second matchup of the day
okay so anyway we've got a very standard
opening here so it's actually turned
into a very
sort of like classical game very classic
approach very slow
slow slow play for both sides which is
why it's called the
uh this is called the the juco
pianissimo
um of course meaning the very slow
version of it as opposed to the juco
piano or
juco piano which is just straightforward
oh that's bold
well logic's got to go back to go
forward here he's got to play knight g5
and
he just does it wow
logic logic logic logic such logical
moves he just
does it he just it's not i couldn't even
finish my sentence
wow doubles in trouble he's got what
he's got to go bishop e2 probably
or f i mean f4 yeah if he plays f4
there's a draw for black i think we'll
see
um we'll see if logic does it or not i'm
not
the problem is logic logical is is a
word that i use a lot to explain certain
moves or ideas so it's like
i'm not trying to make the pun it's just
normally what i would say and so it's
like oh yeah
it's like i really oh my gosh it's going
to happen
please don't play rook d7 or rook d3
uh-huh oh no oh but he wants through
audrey is trying to put the rook behind
the pawn he's trying to show a
deep concept and
double had to go king g2 king f2 because
now he's cut off
right and now the funny thing is now
rook d7 is a great move
the move that tubbo desperately wanted
is actually a great movie
yes to bring the rook back otherwise
rook d8 rook d1 it's game over
this is crazy but both players are i
mean tubbo is now getting a little bit
low on time
as well he's admit he's a buck 20 and
counting he plays it
very nice move by tabo that is a
high-class move rook takes pawn for free
rook d8 rook d1 and that was that was
just was that just game over that was
game over
yeah yeah exactly i mean i think there's
i still think logic has good chances to
draw this game
but it's there's no guarantee now no
guarantee at all
i think this is going to king vs king i
think you're right
but that's what i was talking about now
you check
rook takes pawn is a draw
okay
uh he's got to go all the way back only
move rookie only move yeah okay
i told you no wow
oh my gosh oh oh logic didn't react in
the way like it was a mouse like
though either everyone stay calm
it's still not over i don't think oh wow
this is
oh my gosh but this tub will know how to
check me here is the question
okay so if i go there
you can go there there
there okay king h3 is the only try right
yes change three and then you hope for
rook g5 to create the wrong ladder
yes but king g2 is all right so king h3
oh my gosh he's bringing his king
this is fine i mean i don't love it but
it's still fine
oh my gosh tubbo tabo tabo tubbo use the
queen
use the queen boss man
your king can't check the other king
just use the other two pieces
there there it is there it is there it
is come on come on okay okay not quite
okay oh my god
oh my god
no no
no oh
no
i i don't even
i don't even damn it
logic i want to start with you you were
looking
locked in throughout that match how were
your nerves first of all throughout uh
how was it
to play such a kind of high intensity
match and how are you feeling with the
victory
uh i feel good um yeah tebow plays
really really dope that was super fun i
was extremely nervous
uh i'm on my beth harmon i'm hungover
because last night was valentine's day
and i had a bomb time with my wife
and uh so yeah man i feel great
it's the first time i've ever competed
in my life i don't know if y'all noticed
i grew up broke okay so i couldn't
afford like a basketball jersey to play
on the team or nothing so
this is like my first time ever
competing in anything in my life and i'm
having a blast
uh i guess openings wise taboo my
question for you
is that very first game you seemed
very eager to trade away like you
weren't even phased when the when the
queen drop happened
like from you i
i don't okay so my i don't really know
how to describe what happened there i
was just kind of like well
i could take it and then while i was
still thinking about it i'd already
taken it so
and there wasn't much thought i'll be
honest it wasn't it wasn't
it wasn't some crazy mind games it was
like hmm i could take this oh
oh i've taken it ah gentlemen uh it was
a pleasure to have you on
thank you for a fantastic match we were
we were blown away honestly
you guys continued the streak of
fantastic games here and
we look forward to your next matchups
thank you
you